el congresista republicano George Santos
ha sido acusado de 13 cargos federales y
el mismo se ha declarado inocente ante
el juez esta misma tarde ha salido para
traspagar una fianza de 500.000 dólares
una fianza que ha sido pagada por tres
individuos de los text Se desconoce su
identidad recordemos que George Santos
es el representante republicano por long
island consiguió ese puesto ese escaño
en las pasadas elecciones legislativas
de noviembre del 2022 y un mes después
justo en diciembre ya comenzaron a salir
a la luz varias mentiras que había
contado sobre su trayectoria personal y
profesional Pues bien Ahora se enfrenta
a 13 cargos federales como decía 7 de
ellos por fraude tres más por blanqueo
de capital otro por robo de fondos y dos
más por haber mentido en la cámara de
representantes los fiscales le acusan de
haber pedido dinero de haber re dinero
para su campaña con pretextos falsos y
haberlo utilizado para sus gastos
personales eso entre otras acusaciones
que de confirmarse y salir condenados
enfrenta apenas máximas de hasta 20 años
por cada delito grave Mientras tanto
desde el partido republicano Pues bien
el presidente de la cámara de
representantes Kevin mccarthy ha dicho
que de momento se ha apartado a Santos
de los comités pero no se va a pedir su
dimisión hasta que no se demuestre si es
culpable o no algo con lo que no están
de acuerdo muchos congresistas
republicanos que ya han pedido su
dimisión por los hechos ocurridos el
mismo ha dicho que no va a abandonar su
escaño en el congreso algo que
legalmente no está obligado a hacer a
pesar de haber sido imputado